une dernière patrouille pour s'assurer
que plus personne n'étant détresse le
sergent dogwatt c'est son coéquipier ont
passé plusieurs heures sur les terres
inondées de cette petite communauté
modeste dans les terres de Floride
et débris des contaminants et même des
alligators il ne recommanda personne de
nager ici pas très loin des cadavres ont
été trouvés
une majorité des personnes tuées par
Yann serait des années qui se sont noyés
résident de l'endroit my freeer constate
les dégâts il a eu peur
au prochain ouragan dit-il je ne reste
pas sur place
à quelques kilomètres on assiste à un
autre exemple d'entraide des Banques
Alimentaires distribuent au et
nourriture aussi qui attendent leur tour
plusieurs heures
je suis reconnaissant d'être en vie 17
hommes
je ne sais même pas dans quel état se
trouve ma maison les résidents de
watchoula peuvent difficilement se
déplacer toute l'eau tombée au nord de
l'État redescend vers la mer faisant
déborder les rivières un peu partout
dans la région
dans les villes les plus touchées par
l'ouragan les opérations de secours
continuent donc 5000 membres de la garde
nationale ont été déployés pour évacuer
les sinistrés encore coincés
des écoles et des églises peuvent les
accueillir dit le responsable des
opérations à Nantes
en fin de journée ils sont encore des
dizaines à monter dans les camions
militaires
nous étions entourés d'eau sans
provision 10 meilleurs sitorenzo on nous
a dit que notre maison finirait par être
inondé
le résilience à tous à de coin
impressionner normal nous répondons ici
nous sommes de la Floride on a
l'habitude
[Musique]
qui jean-Sébastien Cloutier Radio-Canada
nom de porte en Floride